la liaison vidéo direct avec vos ce qui
nous permet de discuter en profondeur
des relations entre la chine et la
russie du partenariat stratégique
je considère ses relations vraiment un
exemple de la coopération interétatique
au 21ème siècle
malgré
les limitations sagnier tribune de
logique et qui sont toujours en vigueur
nous restons toujours en contact et en
mai dernier par visioconférence nous
avons lancé un commun la construction de
latéral de quatre unités de la station
nucléaire en chine et en juin dernier
nos amours réalisant une visio
conférence consacrée au 20e anniversaire
du grand traité russo chine nous voir où
nous avons discuté des sujets et guy en
particulier de l'afghanistan le problème
de l'afghanistan cette année s'est
déroulée
sous l'égide et du 20e anniversaire du
traiteur de partenaires est de l'amitié
entre la russie la chine et sa vigueur
et prolonger encore pour le 5 à revenir
et la réalisation de ce document de base
qui reflète les traditions profondes et
historique et de l'amitié de la
compréhension mutuelle entre les peuples
russe et chinois nous a permis de faire
monter des relations au niveau
extrêmement haut supérieur
les deux pires on mise en place ce
nouveau modèle de coopération qui se
base sur les sujets comme la non j'ai
ans aux affaires internes aussi bien que
le respect mutuel des deux parties et
nous avons décidé de transformer les
frontières en
ceinture de l'amitié qui ne permet de
renforcer les relations commerciales et
le chiffre d'affaires a augmenté de 31
pour cent jusqu'à sa mme13 milliards de
dollars ce qui nous a permis de dire on
nous avons
dépassé le record avant les pandémies
par rapport à 2010 9è et comme nous
sommes convenus nous allons dépasser
bientôt
le niveau 2 200 milliards de dollars et
nous sommes en train de réaliser des
projets d'envergure dans l'agriculture
et dans le domaine de haute technologie
et dès le début de la pandémie nous
avons réuni nos efforts visant à abattre
l'infection à coronavirus est et la
chine devient le centre international de
production des vaccins russey spoutnik
mais explique nick knight nous avons
signé les contrats qui permet de
produire tout 250 millions de doses à
part les efforts du six fabricants
chinois en plus nous avons un mécanisme
largy
intergouvernementaux et de différents
ministères entre les deux pays et nous
sommes en train de renforcer la
coopération parlementaire et nous sont
toujours de maintenir les relations
entre nos ministères des affaires
étrangères et de la défense et la
coordination mutuelle sur l'arène
internationale et la proche par rapport
aux problèmes internationaux est devenu
un facteur
d'importance de stabilité et nous
continuons à coopérer sur le site et de
conseil de sécurité de l'onu on nous
conseille au niveau de l organisation de
coopération de shanghai bre x est qui se
base sur le respect de l'ordre mondial
et le respect des deux parties chers
amis chers messieurs les présidents je
considère que en février prochain nous
aurons la possibilité de nous rencontrer
à pékin qu'on ne sont convenus nous
allons réaliser
les négociations et nous allons
participer à l'inauguration des jeux
olympiques d'hiver à pékin aux
opérations de la possibilité d'assister
à cet événement d'importance
évidemment pour nous c'est très
important de continuer la coopération
dans le domaine de sport et surtout
malgré toutes les tentatives les ont à
faire dégrader la coopération de sport
et je suis sûr que ces jeux olympiques
se dérouleront au niveau supérieur ou la
chine n'est vraiment s'y connaît et
j'aimerais me permettre de me rappeler
que nous allons nous sommes mis d'accord
de relais et en 2002 22 et 23 les années
de sport bilatéral entre la russie la
chine et compte tenu du caractère des
relations nous allons discuter des
tâches d'importantes d'actualité en
profitant de la possibilité j'aimerais
vous féliciter et tous nos amis avec le
nouvel de l'ong qui s'approche
j'aimerais souhaiter la bonne heure la
prospérité le meilleur merci beaucoup de
votre attention
monsieur c'est donc mon cher ami de
longue date je suis très content d'avoir
la deuxième vision conférence cet arrêt
c'est la trente septième rencontre que
nous avons avec ou depuis l'année 2013
ces derniers temps dans le cadre de
divers événements vous aviez hautement
évoluée les relations russo chinoises en
les appelant en exemple des opérations
entre les digital au 21e siècle et vos
soutenait les efforts de la chine pour
protéger ses intérêts nationaux clé vous
avez été opposés à des tentatives de
créer des
problème entre nos deux pays
je j'ai apprécié notre relation je suis
prêt à faire le bilan de cette année
a dressé la liste de nos projets pour
renforcer notre coopération dans divers
domaines
pour les intérêts d'une coopération
durable de très haute qualité dans nos
relations nous voyons qu'il ya des
processus
internationaux et de la pandémie qui
sont très intéressants sont
interconnectés le monde a commencé cette
ère de la turbulence notre coopération
russo chinoise a surmonté des épreuves
et air s'est montrée vital
en ouvreur nouvel élan a été donnée à
leurs relations sous diverses formes ont
été gardés les contacts intenses sur les
points principaux de notre agenda les
parties ont annoncé ouvertement et
clairement
le fait que nous prolongeons notre
traité de bon voisinage de coopération
et nous apportons une nouvelle dimension
actuelle dans ce traité nous soutenons
dans des domaines vitaux de notre pays
nous défendons notre
notre dignité nationale et nos intérêts
comme avantage politique l'avantagent
des possibilités c'est ce qu'on voit
dans notre relation bilatérale
pour la première fois depuis trois
trimestres
non-échange ont su remonter aux enquêtes
et des poubelles ont dépassé le chiffre
de 100 milliards de dollars d'ici la fin
de l'année et justement en pour le mois
de novembre ce chiffre sera à la hauteur
de 1300
223 milliards nous sommes en train de
réaliser en nombre de projets
stratégiques
des échanges en monnaie nationale
montrait bien sûr notre coopération
structurelle
sur la construction de nos structures de
coopération
les parties
continuent de promouvoir
notre unité nahla les efforts
internationaux pour lutter contre la
pandémie nous défendons la vraie valeur
de la démocratie des droits de l'homme
ceux qui forment le socle pour les
réalisations jeu des principes et des
multilatéralisme d'égalité et l'année
prochain prochaine aura lieu la 20e
réunion très importante pour notre pays
et la russie entrera dans la tap l'étape
clé de la mise en oeuvre du
développement de son programme des deux
camps d'ici 2030
les parties vont échanger et vont
partager entre eux les les opportunités
pour promouvoir l'agenda international
du développement pour créer un exemple
nos constructions de coopération de
cette nouvelle génération
jeu matin toujours
à ce que vous allez rendre visite en
chine et que vous participerez à
l'ouverture des jeux olympiques
j'attends avec impatience cette réunion
dans le cadre de jeux olympiques nous
allons ouvrir une nouvelle page ensemble
cette ère post pandémique je vous
remercie
cher monsieur le président